[Music]
facility meeting project steering group
first of all i would like to call for
apologies please the mir and grandma
cleared someone like to move that these
apologies be received thank you joining
its and jim palmer place okay all those
in favor please say aye
against carried thank you right we'll
move on to the approval of the previous
minutes which was such a long time ago
27th of february 2000 and 2001 s and
someone like to move these minutes are
true and quick record please thank you
and i'll seeking that mean thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against carried thank you any things you
wish to Metis arising from the minutes
nothing move on now we're just going to
bring the air landscape presentation
forward so Tory would you like to okay
what tour is about to proceed as what we
were obviously trying to do a few months
ago it's very much an overview of the
landscapes it's very much a concept
planned and conceptual overview and tour
we'll take us through that we need to do
some work with other key stakeholders on
this as well so we wanted to have it
here today first but we're going to work
with the era Potter has been confirmed
as the appropriate person for the
Runanga so we're going to arrange a time
with her minute or on a manual where we
can go through both the the tour of the
building and also the concepts for the
landscape in which give us lots of
opportunities for involvement and also
work with this Wharton Ric trusts to
make sure that what we're planning
doesn't actually interfere with how they
like to use some of the exterior space
so as a few bits and pieces to go
through the year so we didn't want Tori
getting too detailed to finalize because
otherwise it doesn't actually make a
real involvement of the other key
stakeholders so maybe tour if you go
through what you've got and then we'll
take questions at the end and these we
next remember over the road from Maria
Andrews in existing hockey here and so
I'm just going to take a few teeth
through a few slides
starting from quite a broad scale and
then hone in on a few right so as I said
I'm sure you're you are all aware of the
positioning but just to take you through
it so we have the sorry the boundaries
of the facility here the area that's
highlighted is the area that's landscape
designed at the moment and you can't see
it now I'm going to talk to you
today and you sort of see the the faded
out areas which which are not included
in this plan
so around licks the new design that's
actually currently about to be tended
the documentation is just getting
finalized for that now
so those crossing points the tour has
been part of that team as well and doing
some mints came across the row but those
crossing points there will be is getting
built up that workers plan to start
around September October this year so
around the boundary of the site we've
proposed some replanting and probably
immediately had drawn to these bright
yellow dots these are my trees we've
proposed some similar conifer plantings
around the outside in especially on this
the southern side here where they
couldn't they wouldn't create any issues
with shade and there's a real
opportunity there to do some larger
plantings conifers tend to grow really
well out there we've had great success
with conifers over the road at symmetry
over here so I think they would do
really well there and the idea is to get
onto their planting and and get them
established so they create their that
boundary and backdrop to the facility in
the rear dots and on the top there along
Coldstream Road some beautiful big
deciduous trees just to create that
really nice entrance Avenue effect
coming into the facility so this is our
main entry into the facility into the
main car back here and again we've got
some proposed tree planting within the
cow park these green strips
swale systems stormwater swells so the
runoff from the compact runs into those
and then you can see out the output
issuing paths into our main entry point
here at that same entry points is a
drop-off visitor job option in Bastrop
offs are in here which exists at that
point there into a proposed second
cataract
yeah this space here is what I'm going
to sort of hone in on soon and talk to
you a few more details about that's the
canopy space and a second entry into the
building which i think is of equal
importance to that entry there really
well we're on the slide there Carpathia
it's not currently part of the current
contract with Leeds at the moment so the
resource can see this one here and this
is all and the reason was consumed we're
starting work at the moment on preparing
the resource consent for the tennis
development councils and the Greek put
some funding into there as part of that
development that will be the additional
car part will create there so that's got
about 45 or 46 cars from memory and
we're hoping to do that as a variation
to lease contracts so effectively when
this building is finished
that car part will be done as well so
that that's why we've got Tories to
include that in the landscaping because
it'll be a vital link for coming across
here so it's not currently in the
contract but it will when we do the
original school sip we're putting it in
and we have to show a landscape plan for
the resource can see anyway so that was
part of the resource consumed in just
the only last thing here sorry but
that's quite a big swale you don't need
some sort of bridge across er that's
indicative at the moment until we've got
the final layer of tennis that's that's
more or less final but not final enough
to actually get dimensions and yet but
there will be it will need to get some
sort of bridge across there for a
petition Nexus way so that one the is
just indicative amount will get the
final plan so I'm just going to speak a
little bit more about this area here and
particularly this this drop-off space
coming around here is Craig seed we
really do need to strengthen the link to
the to the building from this proposed
cap back here and we've done it through
creating foot bridges similar to the one
that Craig was just speaking yet to the
to the east but we've got May
pedestrian exists coming from culturing
road fire that path here so we need to
strengthen that and it also just I guess
with this becoming a drop-off point it
really does become a second entry to the
facility in it sort of needs to be
designed as a welcoming and encouraging
space into the building space I'm just
to give you a bit of a oh and I can flip
back to the other one come back and
forth but just one of these squares here
is around nine metres five six so it'll
give you an idea of just how big that
canopy spaces and to really I guess
there's a risk of it appearing as just a
large expense and not very welcoming so
to to sort of make it feel a little a
little bit more friendly we've proposed
some quite large furniture within that
space in while designing it the most
important thing was was again to
encourage the addition movement in from
from now back in from Italy which was
Dania you have people moving right
across it and to the into here coming
across the year so I've really tried to
strengthen that line and while we have
for that proposed the big furniture in
there I'm sort of keeping it there
pedestrian flow open across here and
we've put a few measurements in here
again just so you can understand the
scale of it but also to show that we can
keep pads clear for service vehicles
emergency vehicles for example them down
here we've got six metres between the
proposed miniature deer in the building
and we do also have these these little
squares and the canopy pumps start some
those into Buddhist tree
and vehicle movement around that space
so I propose large platform so
you think these are these squares here
this sticking here is ground liberal
again to strengthen that that pedestrian
Nexus into the space and but the idea of
those those large platform areas
is is really so a multi-use again to
sort of break up the expense of the
space but also to create an area where
teams might meet they were to get off a
bus and gather there before before
events and just for it for people to
just sit out there and wage and and do
whatever they like really spend some
time within the exposure that's not just
a transitional space they're not just
coming and going moving out of it I'll
just go through quickly some of the
services so if a crow is exposed
aggregate for within these squeeze the
Select green ones here are grass and
then some some plants in areas again to
break up the the surface a little and
make it look a little softer but he's
also the opportunity here to put some
things with a bit of a little bit of
height within it sort of working with
with the vertical element of the canopy
policy here we've proposed some bench
seating and is created the style of
these platform seats in the States we
would really like to get an idea from
I'm speaking to you and speaking to
others of how we Beast bring in the
style and the materials of those and get
a unique flavor I guess to this facility
so just speak a little bit more about
that these are just some ideas these are
the examples that were on their previous
page this is it
crash you cheer Portland you may have
seen it but what I liked about this is
that it brings in some of the landscape
into the design of it and it's quite
unique to it to the face into the
environment that's my little boy roughly
probably doing what he's not me to be
doing on on those say
something hard for them but I guess it
indicates that they can be used in a
variety of ways it could be used by
groups or all by individuals and then
I've just indicated a few materials
which again I think could be really
unique to the project and we can come up
with with some different designs and use
of materials yeah
following on from there there's not a
great deal of space for landscaping at
this entry point but I'd like that
furniture there which I've proposed as a
planter and with plants of a little bit
of height and um timber surround to be
of a similar style to the seating at
this space which I was just just
speaking about and I believe place going
to speak to this one this is the area
which we have costed for the project so
actually tour can we just ah no sorry
um you can you dab it to the slide yeah
so basically at the moment the concept
of this is obviously we've got to refine
it with the other parties but the
concept of it is that all these hard
surfaces here will be exposed egg and
the ash felt will be done by Lee's so
there'll be form part of the contract we
will then probably do these air set when
I say ourselves with our own concrete
which could be lease but they can be
done it quite a late stage when we know
how we are for money so we don't need to
commit to those is off today we do need
to come up to some of this hard
surfacing so basically when we when we
design this building as Warren Amani we
didn't put a lot of design work into
this because we always knew it was
something hit to happen later because at
the time we didn't even know if we were
going to build it financially so our
resource consent at the moment is
subject to a landscaping plan coming so
while we have got resource consent to
proceed we do need
submit a landscaping plan in the current
contract with lease all of this
asheville area is exposed egg suppose a
right around here is exposed to egg
these hard surfaces and here aarush felt
and that was to give you some sort of
dry entryway under your feet so you're
not traveling through grass to get into
the into the doors what we've worked out
and I come have done some costing for
this we could effectively substitute
putting exposed egg in here which is
gonna look quite attractive and I saw
all these grids here to that was exposed
egg and in the contract we're proposing
to put all those grids as Asheville and
then exposed egg and the large squares
as an example that's six point eight by
five point nine meters that's one of the
small ones that's huge areas there is
roughly cost neutral because we take out
all the exposed air key and substitute
of Asheville we get enough to do this
because this is easier laying as well so
basically subsidies reversing what was
in the contract but we do need to be
able to confirm that with lease fairly
soon because they're doing prep and that
very soon but we've got exposed a
examples getting prepared by redirects
now so Tory has lied unified we think of
a suitable exposed egg mix which is what
was that she used wrote Jennifer Center
and reading mixes doing a sample near
for to come back to Warren emollient us
to look at so there so basically that
could be done swapped out now with no
effect on the budget but for the full
landscaping plan now it excludes these
red trees so well they're not read but
the red dots we're proposing to talk to
ring your if the community board about
the teacher using some of the
entranceway
landscaping money they've got to do that
now we haven't been there yet but I have
had a pretty conversation with a couple
of members about it so once we've been
here whatever checked them about there
so in the costume have got done for the
landscaping at the moment we haven't
included that row of trees we haven't
also included this because that can be
done it's
we'll be great to have but that could be
done it sometime when we see how we
going with money so that's excluding so
what we've costed us all of what you've
seen and hear hear and that is there's a
shortfall of what we've got in the
current contract of around 150,000 now
that will vary a bit depending on the
exact seating and beaking a lip which we
get so a comm roster the costume for us
em we just put effectively some
allowances and therefore furniture
because until the detailed designs don't
get costume we don't know but it's
around 150,000 shortfall because we
always knew when the contract went 14
der there was minimalistic mean scoping
that so we knew we had to do more we've
worked and I've looked through the
financials and we think at the moment
that there is enough and the contingency
to a layer for about an extra hundred
and fifty thousand going for landscaping
but there doesn't need to be committed
today because we can wait till much
further down the trip when we actually
do commit any of it so if there's
something unexpected comes which we hope
not of course but now if there's
something which you have to use it for
we're not committing there all we really
need to committed I mean literally today
all we need to do is change those
surfaces I mention annex about that
effectively and the risk can be done at
some stage we'd ideally like it all done
when we open but that's a year away and
we'll get a lot closer with budget and
we'll also get some prices and it may be
cheaper for us to get our own
contractors to price that we're going to
price some ways but it may may be true
for us to do it we don't know we'll
certainly probably use Delta to do the
planting because we tend to get cheaper
rates there so that's their outline
mirrors what we're doing there this
landscaping here I'll net car part will
be down as part of that Tina's contract
so when we let the contract fur because
they're a power of the resource because
if we make the contract so that the
concept with tennis is that we as the
council builds they under servicing for
that courts are fit to be an issue alt
surface and we put power and water
connections and a citrus rectory in now
to the boundary or will be and then the
tennis club's put the final playing
surface on and the nets and feet sing
and whisper so what we'll do there and
we'll do there so we've got
I'm afraid the resource conceit for the
spam there's Whitnall resource consent
for that now and Pell Phoenix are doing
the detailed design in there so that's
how it sort of fits together with a
budget but and and net will get refined
abut further as we get further down the
track with what we're actually doing but
that's the sort of scale of magnitude
and icon spent quite a bit of time go
through what was already in the contract
and that's with Tori you know changing
those surfaces seemed to make my good
good sense but when Richard nor team
were doing we always knew we had to do
some landscaping at NIT it was just done
as a minimalistic thing so we're happy
to take any questions thank you um
probably three questions what is that
building on the south India that's
that's very light no no no on the South
Southie and no no no that building there
what is it it's a large depression in in
the soil surface to collect water all
right that's great thank you I'm with
you this reserved for it all to speak on
expansion right my second question is is
that the intention to plant the
perimeter trees this winter no because
we haven't got any budget for it at the
moment so and that they check with Chris
that's right there's nothing in the
green space budget for the current year
we didn't put anything other than
dividend on keep rates down to this
there's nothing in the year all right
and my feed question is where are we at
with the tennis clubs with my
understanding is that they're going to
put a building
in the middle of the south end and look
just there and as we were weird what
they said has it been planned or have
been designs thrown up yes they have we
need some sort of design to put a
resource concern so they have given a
concept designed to to us so we've got
that so the resource can see it will
actually be for the teen tennis courts
plus the the club rooms in its
associated car parking whether whether
that buildings in a you know win that's
built as another matter because they've
got to get funding for that but on day
one if tennis is operating they can use
the Twitter facilities over over here so
it could operate on day one we will put
we're running power ducks in in water
ducks through through the arena for
building to go in so when there when the
when the ish felt service goes down the
Ducks will be there when the building
hit was we don't know and just last one
I'm lighting is ed included and what's
happening initially for tennis know what
we're doing for tennis is we're getting
a lot him design done we put we as the
council put the ducks in for the likes
to eventually be connector so we put the
cabling in at the appropriate places so
a lighting design as part of the
resource can see and then they install
the lights
so we're basically doing the
infrastructure effectively so when we
sized the transformer for this complex
that was built onto it so there's
provision and that transformer enough
capacity to cope with lights for tennis
and also we don't know in the future but
if these when these sports fields are
developed they couldn't be less as well
we don't know so we've got enough
capacity of the year and we've also ran
a duct down to the about the you
actually the corner that's what's fuel
so we can develop those what's fields
input power if it's desired without
doing that this driveway so the concept
is when this is finished it's finished
and there will be so to where that
building is going to be on the tennis
club yep so they yeah so we'll put a
circle it's good point John and and that
has to be pumped back because there's a
pump system as well so wall Lincoln but
it's a very small capacity compete of us
just just a couple can you go back to
the main the focal plane please great
yet that one the vehicle access that
you've taught there in in the original
concept there needs to be room for food
cuts or something like that to get in
because we can't manufacture food on
site so that's all right even with those
grass spaces that we playing well you've
got a 6 meter carriageway the ER
effectively yeah so it's quite wide to
give you nice food or they could go out
here now yeah no I have no idea I don't
know that's right the theme you've done
a huge area at the front which you know
to teach you they would like because
it's highly visible but ok so there's
plenty of room there the and we Craig
and I have had a week criminally meeting
Michaels concept is that some of the
sports teams we want to warm up yeah so
there's plenty of space for that I take
it my other one was the side door and to
the gym which is they flipped line up on
the top right hand corner he wants to
hear a running trick in the journey
outside so those surfaces will all be
the one evil design now I'm done the
door doesn't have a threshold music so
you come out from that door and that
still there's a 7 meter gap there
between the edge of the building and
that seat okay I mean yeah you know
you're not the indicative running trick
yeah outlined on the plan now just but
it's okay you know I've got no idea what
he's really thinking but I more
conscious of different surfaces with
some might be slippery and others aren't
but I don't even know if he's thinking
of covering it with he was thinking of
the plan is that they'll have a rolled
out artificial year's grass mat taught
using about Dennis has brought me out
okay
no that's called thinking we measured
that when we designed the building to
make sure that there was enough room
yeah okay
thank you quick one in the car park
design for the main car park that we are
trees are and and I like the trees that
you're on where the trees are intended
that was they were provided for in the
car park assessment in terms of they're
not replacing an existing car park so so
they're still given a fit to the
consented requirements of car parks
I've put deciduous at the moment I'm
happy to take some ideas nothing
exceedance time but I've proposed to
said us I've chosen home beam which I'd
say it's a really tidy leaf dropper
while it does drop leaves late autumn
they're quite they're not the sort of
leaves to get all sort of you know gank
things up and that they don't get all
slippery and make a real mess they sort
of they go really dry in sort of almost
blow away yeah so they are deciduous but
I'm happy to take ideas on that if you
prefer an evergreen I'm I'm just
conscious that when you engage with our
Potter and others if the reserve name
has a witch that they've been invited to
submit a name they would probably like
to see represented in there in the
design of the broader scheme native
features so that's why I just raised
that as a as a meta to think about
absolutely right and that's why we
didn't want to get this to developed
because otherwise our part will be
getting to rel and we would like to have
discussion with and get his feedback on
all those aspects because you're
absolutely right whatever they're
thinking off and also they may have
we've talked the conifers here but you
know they may have our preference for
whatever I don't know but yeah that's
why we wanted to not get this much more
developed their owners now to actually
start those conversations otherwise
we're sort of a but saying this is what
we're building rather you know and
there's also potential in in in here if
if there's some patent he wants in you
know like you did patent and some of the
squeeze the seats the but you know there
is potential for this sort of as well
once
and the concept of that is we'll meet in
a quorum onion will have the 3d
walkthrough often building as well as
this so he gets an overall impression of
scale and language too because they're
that 3d one who won money of God is
really good for getting their hyped and
if you only seen one day plan what's
quite different I can see a desire
particularly in the forecourt spaces for
a there to be a significant design
component and probably reflected in the
selection of vegetation they're all
planting that might go in there as well
I suspect lighting for their canopy area
I understand because there is a fighting
on the outside of building which can be
pointed in different directions and
there's also some lighting poles in
various areas as well but the lighting
for the canopy we might have to give
some consideration to just because of
the sheer scale of it and it may have
already been considered but if we're
putting some a more plainer to drop-off
area then you've got a large piece in
the middle which is gonna have to be
well lit because a lot of playing time
is going to be winter after dark yeah I
think it's a very good point lamp
I'd have to go back to tell Felix
Tony who did the lion design but I do
remember that being discussed when I
carry on what the outcome was but I know
it was talked about and and I had a
feeling but I could be completely wrong
because I had a feeling that sort of
down there there was some lighting but I
but we were all chief Richard might know
I think that we may have got as far as
provision for cabling in the frame
awaiting selection of fittings depending
on what the outcome was so the idea
Chris would be overhead lighting for the
for the reasons you raise but obviously
subject to confirmation as well as
it's developed yeah thank you for that
now got my memory Creek Tony was we were
to produce a landscaping plan and then
come back to Tony's right thus cabling
lien our but he wanted to get this sort
of thing done so we're going to come
back to him so this this cabling being
put them all the top but it's we've got
to come back to him with the landscaping
design so he can get the lights right
and it is potentially possible to bring
us some I mean all these corners are
poles so it is possible to mount the
speedy mounting spaces there but he
definitely wants to look at this one one
other question on the on the west side
of the building and the south side there
that appears to be a swale all the way
around there in terms of flat access for
building maintenance is there sufficient
room for vehicles to you know and I'm
thinking about a higher that may be
needed to deal with any matter on that
west side of that building whether that
can help whether there is sufficient
space between the building footprint and
the Swale to enable I'll call it a
maintenance maintenance vehicle to
safely anchor there
you've actually got a two-meter ash fell
path that runs down the side you see
that gray section between the Swale
that's that's free height so you could
get a scissor lift or something down
that path of 2 meters but the depression
of the swelling isn't a huge amount it's
not a really very deep swell it's just a
runoff channel really so it's actually
quite wide but quite shallow so if you
need to mow that swell you could easily
get that mode as well that's why we get
a snow event and we end up with
something that needs sorting at the top
on the roof from that side you don't
want to have to scaffold it or anything
outrageous like that
you
um so do we comply with the fire exits
and fire compliance with just a 2 meter
on it with it so that's why the two
meters of there you see those fire doors
along the edge of the plane no the fire
truck could just drive the Jason to the
building the two meters of getting
people out so if there's a crowd exiting
out they've got room to beat alongside
of the building and unobstructed way yep
yeah the strategy is the fire truck will
use the the main carpark the actual fire
connection I for this for the for the
connection of the truck is actually in
the access way between halfway down that
car apartments for the access way into
the tennis area so the intention is the
truck will come racing up that drive and
then it will connect into its hose point
there and then it will fight the fire
from that east side the west side is
literally just for occupation a cue you
know to get out the actual fighting on
the fire will be dealt with elsewhere
and also the SVR rims on that east side
as well so they'll be connecting in to
that so that'll be their main point for
fighting any fires go for it it's part
of the design we actually met with this
room it's you in it with fire service
the local fire service as well as contra
one so the local one's been and they
were heavily involved in the design with
Darrell from the homes fire they did all
this and no very happy with it the way
it's configured because we did that
quite early on to make sure it wasn't
gonna be an issue later christian
territory plays they the planting alarm
in that car park area and also long the
main road Yuriko stream road is that you
know bearing in mind with the the
dampness and in
we're not wanting to shade too much in
that area is that important to have a
different type of planting there rather
than a heavy Bush type I think not only
the visual aspect of having deciduous
trees along there but with being the
read dots but also here to all stop
shaving beneath it at the moment we've
only proposed grass for the advantage
which I think would be sort of a nice
visual relief you can see right into
there I haven't proposed any planting so
in the car parking itself
what type of planting do you doing that
smaller short long sort some higher yes
the spouse would predominantly be grass
so they can be mom I show her great so
you can but beneath the chase a small
shop not most likely and native yep
thank you give a nice visual one a fun
may be so bold the future hockey field
which isn't in the planer is it just
gonna be grass at the moment we're
hoping us to have that completed and
endless all completed
Tina some stage may be done at the same
time who knows this listen here this and
this will we've got color of topsoil on
site down there's big mounds pairs just
to spread that roughly and I say roughly
it won't be won't be lazily or anything
else just roughly and then just grasped
so we've done it with Grant removed from
green space and these play with it so we
think we've got previous thought there's
actually quite a big drop on the side
the unit's doesn't show up the but city
quite a big cycling is very uneven
ground the Atlanta's huge big tivities
in it so it doesn't eat quite a bit of
length it's
too bad actually but that's the West
area so yeah we'll just grass all that
and then leave it and they're all just
been mowed with a big tractor mouse
that's pretty cheap - yeah cheap to
maintain and it will be open for you so
equally I can trust to be able to use I
understand that you do that building
there doesn't exist now sorry
quick question you Maura comment thanks
Tori we as Craig mentioned in is the the
rooms are where we have real good 3d
model of the building and they're in the
canopy space so we can populate it when
you're ready with some elements so that
perhaps next meeting whatever there's
something to show in terms of the scale
and the arrangement of things I think it
just as a comment it's I think it's
really marvelous that this whole part of
the project is likely to proceed in some
form because although you know huge
amount of effort has gone into the
what's inside the building in terms of
the use of it this will be a seriously
valuable space you know facing north
northwest it'll be sunny it'll be
sheltered in the story and Craig have
mentioned when big groups of people
arrived by bus it is actually really the
real front door of the building though
they all sort of discharged and have
plenty of room to meet and it's Don
seeing the sort of training and moving
around and doing of things and they'll
come and that what we've always talked
about is the second front door which I
think when people arrive on this will
actually be the front door because the
carpark side has really understood for
people who are arriving by car and small
groups and they'll just come in and
there's not a lot of gathering space
there for any large numbers of people so
I guess in my long-winded way of what
I'm saying is that if we can populate
that outdoor room which is what it is
with the kinds of things that Tory's
proposing which are essentially a mix of
hard paving and grass in these island
elements
I think it'll be really useful and
really compelling and it'll be the sort
of part of the mental picture of the
building that people have in their mind
when they think right we're going to go
to this facility that's the bit that
they will be thinking of and really all
the functional things that we've seen so
much time nothing out will be bare
ground in their mind so yeah I think
it's great and it's nicely organized
that we don't have to commit to the
expenditure and toward the end of the
job and we know we were at which i think
is great
so thank you perfect well I've got very
little to update that Craig won't cover
and the report other than things are
steaming along nicely they have not been
no dramatic holdups or changes or things
that have been discovered Craig will
report on what has been going on there's
obviously been a program adjustment as a
result of the lockdown but again the
impact of that has been fairly minimal
remarkably and I think we're so
fortunate that we're under way before
all that unfolded fairly seriously so
the disruption wasn't so big
yes I think that's all I have to say
really on that one any questions you'd
like to thank you right well we move on
into the project manager's report please
which we do have an attached exist at
the outset and I want to say that the
staff and meaning but it was better to
spend the time the landscaping that like
to pass on councils appreciation to the
way that a common more Nnamani Anneliese
keep going through the lockdown there
was lots and lots of emails and phone
calls and and you know we did actually
make although obviously no progress on
the ground but there's a lot a lot of
shop drawings getting processed and a
lot of the leaves were spending a lot of
time
or an Imani and they come just working
at some of the detail that we hadn't
actually addressed at the time when you
had to be done so while we've lost a
month in terms of the actual program I
think that month that we were shut down
I'm very grateful the way that a common
more and Emani work and read it made no
difference would have been nice and
amazing person that certainly from the
comfort of my house I could be talking
to her
various people at various times and it
was really good and you didn't really
notice from the big different
backgrounds when I was talking to Andy
or one it was all just much the same so
I think we're we're very grateful
particularly grateful for the way that
Lee's used it opportunity to keep
progressing shop drawings and the other
thing that Lee's been very good with
who've had some conversations with them
because one of the big risks down there
now with the effect of the viruses this
supply chain and timing which we just
don't know
no one does so what they've done they
already were well advanced in terms of
placing orders for everything the first
trip get a bit more to get some earlier
delivery so that it doesn't hold up the
project so we've got cleaning we've got
the luxury space up the says piña room
to store stuff we need a container
whatever they've got one they can put up
the S oh there they are working very
hard now to get orders confirmed for
everything and get stuff arriving
because there is that risk no one knows
what the outcome will be but the sooner
stuff gets here the better and we have
also we were very lucky if the lockdown
had to happen I couldn't be in a bit of
time for the project because basically
the big cranes were able to be removed
also for the steel and didn't have to
come back so there was no doubling up of
that so in the lockdown we're allowed to
start they started that day because they
had all the roofing material there
there's a lot of maturity and they could
start working on the concrete as well so
the the new completion date the agreeing
will be the 18th of June which the
factories a month later than the
original one so it's what we delay and
of course we don't know that could still
be with the delays but there happens in
any contract but now in terms of the
actual rock down I think it's seemed
pretty realistic to us and we got them
to propose a program we
tell them what it had to be we waited
for them to do a program and they feel
quite confident that they will be able
to deliver on that and certainly at the
moment they're pretty much on track I
mean this with this week hasn't been
great but it would improve so that's in
that report then notes the new
contractor profession date we've also
done some work come and you know meet
yesterday with our building team with
Kathy Stubbs because most of you
remember that when we got the board of
consent for the project we excluded the
reception juice counter and why Ramon
you have done some more work on that so
we met with them yesterday and we're
just gonna get back to seeing but
there's just a couple of really minor
tweaks which only an architect would
notice and that's read to be large so
we'll lodge that we've it meets the food
hygiene handling requirements to quite
strict so we're pretty confident we
should be able to go ahead and get that
done that amendment lodged and then it's
a couple of weeks sort of things so it's
very minor very minor amendments which
is positive as I've already mentioned
we've got agreement with from the rune I
know what era parter is definitely the
person to be working with I've made
contact with him just got cheap with
Richard at a time to come unto Warren
Imani and will bring Torian as well but
I think that's quite keen to get
involved with that and it's really
important I think he gets that to speak
of them off the building hints there
being we're on a money officers the
report will say you're a member gains
had to remember as months ago but we had
had a discussion like last year actually
about some flooring changes so that the
trust was in a potentially stronger
position maybe to negotiate have been a
deal with for the primer supplying
potentially doing their other rubber
flooring and all that area we lodged
that with leaves we've hit the price
confirm now back and you'll see that in
the report was a creative seventy two
three nine eight forty so this group
doesn't have the power to amend the
heads of agreement because the heeds
agreement has a million dollar
contribution from the trust about we
have to be report to Council
because council is the only one who can
do that so you're asked as a group
to support staff preparing a report for
council on that basis otherwise I'm
happy to take our the only other thing
as the good news that the one of the
other concerns that the earth from Lees
has always been we know who get the
major power supply connected because the
attempt repair was very light to
capacity so it wasn't stunning - it was
in danger of holding up the building
project and anyway the good news is just
hearing from these before there's no
power in sight today and they're putting
in the the transform was already been
there but it was a tree lock down but
they're connecting today that means
they'll get the full power supply which
again will avoid any holdups in the
future so I hope if that connection
works so we're not we normally got there
a theater we're not today because
there's no power but so that's good news
that's actually happening and it also
means that the the roading project won't
be affected either because there was a
there's a power pole lien up now for the
tip repair supply which is about better
theory actually roughly so it was going
to be we need to get this gone before
the the writing contract could start so
it's about to kind of tender now and at
the moment the timeframe we work with
leasing and with our team from PDU who
are doing their project and Joey in a
sector that we need services on fairly
soon because at the moment we can't do
any water testing because there's no
water so what the plan is now that we'll
have a water connection through by if
all goes well and the council accepts
the tender by December and so at the
same time so the water and sewer ducts
have to come down next side of the road
and then come across so we've got them
the contract to lease Hisle to the gate
now so under the timeframe that we're
working to dates and going out the
teensiest be completed by December
which mean that Lee's can do all that
testing next year which they'll need to
to get commissioning the Sutra
because nothing worse than being too far
down the track and trying to water
tester water pressure test and then
finally but unless you so they've done
some preliminary tests with pumps but
it's pretty hard to do too much more so
that's that's good that that's happening
and Lisa said that the oldest working
with the with the roadworks is isn't
hitless but the good thing is the hockey
the main traffic for hockey will be over
I mean there is some some early play but
it's not much and game Murray Rangers
went being much use either the in so
it's the work means that reception to
other users generally will be minimized
and happy to answer any questions
anyone's got how can we help time of
managing the road so they went when
we've got to tend elite they are aware
of the design when we've got a team
delete and we have a contract but it is
to two questions and thanks for your
update and report progress looks great
supply chain continuity and clearly
getting the steel here was fundamental
to the project in in your mind there any
you know are there any elements of the
building that are dependent on
international supply chain which are the
most critical or sensitive from your
perspective so that's the first question
and the second
likes to leaves I see and great for them
they've been very successful and secure
and a major Antarctic contract out of
Christchurch which is awesome
do you anticipate that having any impact
on their capacity or focus for this Pro
release won't Fester the I'm sorry kept
me with the gentleman's name now it
should but the regional at Southern
Regional Manager Lee's rang me to tell
me about the entire contract before it
was announced publicly and did reassure
me that it wasn't going to impact on our
contract and he also was very good in
terms of the lockdown hearing at the
start of the lockdown and really during
the lockdown
I've got three occasions to check the
we're all still happy so I think they're
very mindful of keeping mini projects
going so I'm not too concerned a bit
there and I've been actually very
pleased with the level at which they had
gone to to try and keep that higher
level you know dialogue going which has
been really good I've certainly had the
day the lockdown was announced by
government he called me afternoon the
next morning so it's been being pretty
good I mean he did ring me about the the
day it was being publicized as it were
he did really so not to worry about
there mmm yeah yeah there's a lot of
thing I mean with the roofing is the in
our so we've got the immediate stuff a
sort of which is great ins as she going
up the the flooring is you know it's
funny you look we're something
supposedly manufactured neither
conversation the other day whether
plumbing supplies in your myth from taps
are assembled and use your lumber
actually not made here because component
parts so a lot of things that may be
saying they're coming from Australia but
that doesn't necessarily mean there's
not components still coming from
overseas so that the flooring a cetera
has been ordered well in advance in they
don't see any issues with that the heat
pumps are probably the major item that
are obviously made on demand and can you
notice with it see
and in units armed components come from
the Far East but they're fabricated and
manufactured in Auckland so that's not
too much of a risk the biggest risk to
the project is the timber flooring which
we know that's coming from America so
obviously that's probably our our
biggest risk item we've placed forward
orders for it and we've also placed
forward orders for the retractable
ceiling which is also coming from the
state so they're that they're that they
the two key items and in fairness
they're the two key elements to the
project the remaining materials and
components in the most they're coming
from in terms of the specific sports
equipment are coming from Australia so
we should be okay with those as a risk
and the remaining we are working
constantly with the with Warriner Marnie
and lease two to establish any key
things like ceramic tiles things like
that that potentially were coming from
Europe and whether we can mitigate some
of those processes I'm the big one we're
getting from Europe at the moment is
ceramic tiles we have stuck with them
because they've committed to to the
delivery dates we don't need those for
nearly eight to ten months but we're
placing orders now so we're doing
everything we can to give us a window
we're expecting a delay so we're
expecting to get well we're not going to
achieve the target date but we're
actually forward ordering though so we
can have a little bit of slack in that
program to allow for that and anything
we can re specify we are to to just try
and make sure that we either can source
from New Zealand or Australia within the
trans-tasman
area I suppose is the best way problem
is this flooring does enlarge come from
Europe so we're sort of a little bit
stuck from Europe either the carpets
ceramic tiles the the gym floor is so
special st if it was specified by wham
through historic projects there was
nowhere else we could go for it but we
we established that that was
to be the key item that could be could
be a downfall so we we've picked it up
with being constant contact with them
over there and they have the surest that
they can still supply we have to take a
view on that
as a supplier so we were just trying our
best to try and get that all together in
and get it on a ship and then we can
deal with what we we can from there yeah
Jim I think they prognosis for all of us
you know we were much more concerned
eight weeks ago but I think now
manufacturing chains are coming back to
life quite heavily so I think we should
be fine generally and see my store I
would like to share your optimism we're
going to end up in a second and
continuing glow Waihi doom of high
levels so getting those critical
components out of those countries as
soon as I think is really important to
the critical path yes I think I think
from from a risk assessment in spective
knowing that we've got a quantity of
timber owner on a ship in transit but to
be fair you know we may be saying we it
these are driving this they're very
mindful of the need to get and we did
commit as a council saying we're happy
to pay when materials are on site so we
will be paying a bit earlier than we
would have been but that's this file so
I've got doubting anybody's commitment
to do the right thing for the project as
early as possible and that's it's
absolutely awesome
I'm just trying to understand what our
you know when it does go if it could go
wrong we will it go wrong and what
impact it will have and what it's saying
to us as it could have quite a
significant impact if it went wrong but
you try and you can to manage it Nitz we
can ask so and the floor and we don't
want to substitute because we did a lot
of work on a money on the right flooring
at the time so that's the one thing if
we have to substitute some tiles
something that's fine but the the
flooring and the indoor courts that's
the you know there's much in critical to
get from their supplier because any
other building around
she's other products have had issues so
we really do want to so that's why leads
are confirmed orders for and they also
commented to Indian I about their
subbies as well that they wouldn't
closely with the subbies they weren't
used subbies haven't at least got a
track record of successful completion of
projects over five years they won't take
anyone else and they have substituted a
couple nail painting has changed and
something else's Jenner substituted
their decorator who and their initial
their initially appointed subjective
they just didn't have a long-standing
career with as lead so they felt that
that was a risk I'm so they've they've
changed tact and I've gone to a
different supplier just to secure you
know we're in some uncertain times so
they're just managing their own risk
move this recommendation on the project
managers report please Joan thank you
Jim Thank You Joan would you like to
speak no I'm just I'm really thrilled
they had everything's going along very
well good great confidence and Craig and
leis and the team a common in them
looking forward to seeing seeing the
finished product and filling it up so
I'm very excited oh you can I just pick
not just reinforcing what Craig said
earlier I just acknowledge the effort
and work that the whole team has put to
keeping the project on track and
progressing and the way in which that's
happening really pleased to see the way
you're working together and Craig thank
you for your ongoing stewardship of the
project always appreciate it's a good
report good progress up to as all things
considered I don't think we could hope
to be in a better place than we are on
this project so well done and forth look
forward to my pessimistic premonitions
not coming to the fore and the world the
world tracks along gaily and merely say
thank you very much to the whole team
it's wonderful to see this up to where
at us and hopefully we can we can keep
it on track and be lovely with the
flooring so you may recall that we had
organized a site meeting they can March
I think from memory that was going to be
after work create after work now it
doesn't work because it's too dark I've
had a conversation with me and he's
happy if we arrange a Saturday meeting
because I was it because if we go during
the week
Finley's have to shut down the site for
us to be on and so we none of us want to
delay the
say I was going to catch up with Cal
today from lease but I'll choose Disney
Tuesday
so I'll tee something up and I'll with
Mia's diary with Rosie will send a up
that works but that's probably the least
disruptive to to them on a still day
like once we get back a crystal you know
September October then after work
meeting so much easier but just took
nine minutes it's too dark so it hasn't
been forgotten all those in favor that
the recommendation be approved against
its carried thank you now we're just
going to move on Ross yes right Ross
please okay final report number seven go
to the 17th of June construction budget
as we know twenty four point eight six
six million dollars of which the
continuously is one point two seven one
progress claims one to eight have been
certified so I'm out paid today to seven
point six million pretty much through
discussion continue see a list of active
construction instructions and their cost
implications are to the realer what as
usual and a total forecast contingency
expenditure of 489 thousands of which
541 like estimators and fifty-two
negative is agreed I was going to say
that if we're third of the way through
on progressed claims and we're a third
of the way through my construction
contingency that's sort of tracking very
well especially as the covert nineteen
claimers within that dude
so does increase it's actually a
decrease increased by super $36,000 in a
month and the five main items were a
credit
the sprinkler valve room hydraulic
changes there was an on-site retention
of asbestos
contaminator fill which came in cheaper
than we expected it was great the floor
boxes to the main courts there more of
them and there are more complex and
expensive to do so it up there's a
diaphragm ceiling coordination and I
think Dave Andy has mentioned that city
still it needs to ceiling layer and
maybe it's potential for a critter we
didn't know that we may change some of
the ceilings to suit in some areas where
we've effectively got a structural
diaphragm in plasterboard above and then
we have originally designed a suspended
ceiling below we are just going through
that to see whether there is actually a
requirement I have effectively two
seasons and whether whether the room
itself can just be sufficiently
functional for just having a past of all
ceiling rather than a suspended ceiling
so that may produce a credit but we're
just working through that now and that
will probably arrive in next month's
just a question from the Acronis if we
may only have one ceiling it's it's
going to have enough room in it so
there's no gonna be condensation drop or
anything like that I know that that's
there won't be any issue there at all
the only one we're working through at
the moment is whether we can get the
acoustics at the right rating with the
possible ceiling because it's
effectively it's a hard surface the
current design has a acoustic tile in it
so it softens it's you may know or may
not know it's the center admin area so
it's where the administration guys are
going to be sitting on a daily basis so
it needs to be an office space rather
than there just an in-and-out space so
we just need to make sure that the
Lighting's right in the acoustics are in
their large scale so good item of
$30,000 unfortunately and were the guys
in our office misunderstood the drawing
his musical way into what was actually
in reality so it was a sadly a cost so
come to 36,000 extra so you can see the
graph is quite good how it's just going
up you know me so 38 percent of the
construction contingency budget is now
expended of the page risks so it's the
same as last time
still the impact to the covered 19
outbreak sort of summarizing Jim has
summarized those things material
procurement in program further
contaminated material exposed during
excavation obviously begin towards the
end of it it may be a bit more and the
cost of Floyd against Waterloo of the
Wrigley poll which is the cash flow you
can see this falling behind but
obviously mainly because of covert I
don't think we've got the new program
yet and we've got a new program use
every two from Lees to plug into our
cash flow yes we have B pass through so
the UT claim arrived last month it's
been reviewed and processed and approved
so it can now be slow because some of
the ordering
yeah it's gonna change when some of that
cash so these are working on that at the
moment and it's great fuse the feeling
soon I was in the report any questions
just an obvious question but some no
doubts that these would have got
reimbursed with the shutdown through the
government's would they would have been
headed subsea wage subsidy the it's good
creaturely and I kind of perused the
claim quite thoroughly before we had
approved it for payment
leaves have been very transparent and
their claim so they they gave us
detailed itemized list of all of the
component parts
of what there potentially I would have
claimed and then they showed a series of
reductions and the weight subsidy was
all part of that so a common reviewed it
quite carefully in it has been agreed
and a week process so they were in
spirit leave that we had the receipt of
the of the financial report right suit
again one is in favor say aye against
Kerry thank you very much
we won't have the general business they
wish to discuss I think probably Thresh
they doubt just one thing for clarity
after this meeting we will issue the
instruction to the Lee's to change
though that hard surfacing so we'll
substitute the supposed egg as we showed
on the plan so I will do that this week
and but we're not covering to anything
else it's just that they're changing the
hard service and all all the rest of the
there's no commitment to that either
just the hard surface and because
there's a feeding them because they're
working with really mixing yeah so we
need to get that sorted thank you
questions or comments tomato all to
clear the meeting closed at 11:43 thank
you very much
you